I need to tell you something oh my gosh
what
I can't wait to see you girl
when I hear of people falling madly in
love online I kind of roll my eyes a
little but it's happened to me
never met violin in person but now it's
happening I'm going to Vietnam Vietnam
man look at you beautiful and if things
work out I'm ready to spend the rest of
my life with her
everything
is done
[Music]
this is her last chance to recognize
this part I'm not wearing a bra you're
gonna film
no baby
seven years
of talking about this moment
Nikola is the love of my life but he is
so different from anyone else I have
ever been with oh my gosh he is a 46
year old virgin I know how women operate
I know everything
[Music]
foreign
what if my son cannot connect with TV
because he is deaf
[Music]
my girlfriend lives in Barbados I've
never been in love before but I'm ready
to be like husband wife
this is escort page this is her right
oh man
it's not fair for you to do this to me
she's the first person that I've been
with since the death of my husband I
wanted you to be the right person but
maybe we're just not right for each
other
who's that
so little now
I put his shirt off and you won't show
me who it is he's just a friend you liar
you lie I'm getting really worried you
cheating on me
Europe
I'm gonna go my ex he knows how to he's
the best I have ever had you I'm done
[Music]